[Applause]
[Music]
not crazy about it hey hey hey hey
yes happy Thursday everybody so Ron
DeSantis announced his candidacy which
means it's time for
[Music]
you go straight out
spin handles
[Music]
campaign
[Applause]
that was terrible I said to Gene make it
bad
Mission accomplice
so uh it happened during an audio stream
with Elon Musk on Twitter but there were
technical glitches that prevented the
Florida governor from speaking for about
25 minutes which prompted Biden's press
team to ask any way you can hook us up
with those glitches
meanwhile musk already dealt with those
responsible
oh Wise Guys
and you did
get out it does look like musk but the
conversation eventually got going and
lasted about an hour we pause now to
listen to all of it
well I am running for president of the
United States
all right that's enough
not the first time I promised an hour
and finished in seconds
I don't know what that means
later Ron stopped by to chat with our
Powell Trey Gowdy shortly afterwards
despite their differences on what
constitutes a good haircut
you know I'm beginning to think Trey
doesn't go to a barber he just sticks
his head into the world's largest pencil
sharpener
but I wonder Ron do we know if the
country's on the wrong track
we know the country's on the wrong track
we see it with our eyes we feel it in
our bones we see the Border being
overrun we see crime infesting the
cities we see the federal government
making it more difficult for families to
make ends meet and we have a president
who is a listless vessel
listless that is so untrue Biden's got a
lot of lists look at this one
I'll read it
put on shoes after socks don't put on
socks after shoes only shake hands with
real people
the person named Jill is your wife
but to sand it makes it clear our
country's off track something Biden and
friends will never admit even when
trains literally go off the tracks Joe
treats derailments the way he treats
unplanned grandchildren like they never
happened
but Ron better be ready to rumble
because the media and the Dem see him
not just as a huge threat but also evil
and their mouths are foaming like Kevin
Spacey watching a little league game
I don't get it Vanity Fair came up with
this headline Ron DeSantis will formally
announce his 2024 bid with Elon Musk
because apparently David Duke wasn't
available
so really a David Duke reference he's
almost as irrelevant as Vanity Fair but
that shows you how all of those white
supremacists are the are the fabric of
imaginations when the only ones the
media can actually reference is a loser
from decades ago
and failed presidential candidates are
chiming into
this old clam tweeted
Ron DeSantis Ultra Maga Florida isn't
safe for people of color
lgbtq plus people or even multi-billion
dollar corporations
is it safe I bet it's probably safer
than being a former friend of Hillary
allegedly
so it's more the same lie going back to
Florida's so-called don't say gay Bill
remember that that the Santa signed do
you remember the don't say gay Bill
behold
don't say gay bill
[Laughter]
they actually that never happened the
bill could have said Florida residents
get free rainbow penis pouch bikinis in
a case of Bud Light and the media would
still say it's anti-gay because her
strategy as always is to demonize see
even if you think Ron is Trump without
the drama it's not gonna matter with the
help of the media they create the drama
and then it blames you it's like they
set their own hair on fire then call you
the arsonist so it's stupid to think
things will be less contentious with a
non-trump candidate they'll be called
evil from the start which allows then
for them to commit all crimes hell
they'll even fix an election if they're
fighting Hitler here's the CNN Headline
from today why DeSantis is just as
dangerous as Trump or more you see that
and here we were told that Trump was an
existential threat so it's the santis
and extra existential threat how is that
possible he's not just evil he's double
secret super Maggie evil
poor CNN just like Jeffrey tuben they
screwed themselves
if you don't say DeSantis is as bad as
Trump that's an endorsement for DeSantis
and if you say he's worse than Trump
than you expose your previous hysteria
for what it was
so accept expect more of this
it's obvious that Ron DeSantis is a
white supremacist right I I don't want
to dislike you I can't help it why do
you dislike people of color what's wrong
with American history yeah what's wrong
with gay folks this is not a freedom
agenda this is a do what Ron DeSantis
tells you to do the state owns you
agenda as you can see the demonization
is up and sprinting like a trans girl in
a high school track meet
and you don't have to beat Trump or even
White
look at new candidate Tim Scott
he's one of these guys who you know he's
like Clarence Thomas black Republican
who believes in pulling himself by your
bootstraps rather than to me
understanding the systemic racism that
African Americans face in this country
and other minorities he doesn't get it
neither does uh Clarence right and
that's why they're Republicans well
thank you for explaining to us what it's
like to be black in America you 80 year
old white hag who once wore blackface
yeah
yeah she's fugly no matter what the
color
[Laughter]
balls to be a white woman lecturing
black men on being black
maybe she does
bottom line if the GOP has any plans to
win they've got to come out swinging
Like Larry Kudlow at nude volleyball
write an image huh
but don't pretend that if Trump's out of
the picture those never trumpers are
just going to return to the fold no they
still hate you for liking Trump so if
you were hoping for a calmer election
don't kid yourself they want to destroy
you as much as they want to destroy the
candidates perhaps they want you dead
because then they could count on you to
vote Democrat
thanks
yeah let's welcome
tonight's guests
thinks outside the box
sleeps in one at night founder of the
loftusparty.com Michael Loftus
[Applause]
today was two weeks ago and she's still
hung over Fox News anchor Julie Banderas
[Applause]
she's like the Manhattan D.A because she
never lets it finish a sentence Fox News
contributor Kat too
thank you
and finally he's got his head in the
clouds literally my massive sidekick in
the nwa's World Heavyweight Champion
Tyres
I I have to go in reverse order tonight
because as we were playing uh Joy Behar
I could hear uh Tyrus uh uh my pronoun
was you yes yes
you know how do you feel about her
giving you information on what it's like
to be black yeah well I'd like to give
her some information what it's like to
be a
she's uh this is
is why
the elite left like her pushed racism so
much everything's racism I'm a white
supremacist all this stuff so they can
have the it's enough of it out there to
where they can say what they want to say
it was so hard for her not to say what
she really wanted to say if you go back
and watch that these
guys
that's not the word she wanted to use
she just any black man that's successful
on his own and has his own way of
thinking clearly can't be black because
they know what black people are they
need them they can't do things without
them and probably the most the saddest
thing was watching Sonny sit there and
co-sign because it's never about color
it's about them if you're not voting and
there's the don't it is only us brothers
that we have to work so hard to get to a
certain place then we get there and
supposedly we hop through all these
hurdles and they want to praise us but
as soon as we don't do what they want to
do we weren't black in the first place
so can I have my white privilege then
yeah like make up your mind which if I'm
not black what am I now yes because I'm
certainly not going to be able to be
white yeah and she gets away with this
because it was and it's even on their
own show Whoopi Goldberg made comments
about what she thought the Jewish
experience was based off her ideas as a
black woman she had to apologize and she
was kicked off the air for a week yeah
AR can sit up there and it's basically
called
Scott and the Supreme Court Uncle Toms
and get away with it and no one says
anything about it because
that we're all racist she's not she's
just pointing it out she used
Republicans as a term for Uncle Tom's
it's disgusting and this they get away
with it and it's shameful yeah Julie
good to see you as always and to stop I
know I am lying you noticed I was lying
right then and there you didn't even you
didn't even let me finish isn't it
interesting though that no matter what
Republican is put forward they're always
going to be more evil than the one
before it so why why why even think that
there's going to be no drama I mean the
fact that she used racism and then
Clarence Thomas in the same sentence and
then she's like but they're Republican
so I guess you can't be Republican in
Black right he's a genius yeah and and
it's interesting that she had Sonny
Austin sitting right next to her as a
minority and she didn't say a word so it
just goes to show they don't have an
actual spine they don't have a backbone
they're just preaching to the choir
which is their liberal audience and
that's all they want to hear and of
course if you're black God forbid you
have conservative values that's
despicable and that's also just that's
just protruding more hate onto the
American public and on to the ignorant
viewers that watch the show and actually
buy them that they're selling they
actually tune in to listen to her
expertise as a white 80 year old woman
talk about what the black man suffers
come on seriously oh and I just want to
say something about Ron DeSantis
announcing on Twitter stupid really that
was a bad move I like Ron DeSantis I
just thought that was a bad move he's
trying to a 44 year old presidential
candidate elect he would like to become
one he goes on Twitter thinking oh
social media young people blah blah blah
that was a bad choice that's interesting
do you agree uh Michael uh Twitter is a
social media platform that people with
phones and the internet have living on
the street you have no uh you have no
familiarity with anything electrical you
always have to tap into other people's
lines we yeah we do dumpster talk yes
where you raise the lid and you scream
into it it echoes to the next dumpster
over that's amazing hobo Joe's coming in
with a fresh can of me
uh I think the Twitter thing was great
that was a good announcement everybody's
talking about it and I think the Twitter
staff now is what it's Elon Musk and two
dudes and a strong parent is you know
and then half the time Elon takes off
early to build a rocket it's it's wild
to see the left get so emboldened like
like you know everybody's just gonna do
search and replace articles you know
they'll write the most horrific thing
about Trump and then if the scientist is
the guy that we can replace so DeSantis
will be the mother of all evils I I
can't get past the Hillary Clinton with
her little warning tweet about Florida
yeah like Florida is not safe like
that's a warning coming from that yeah
right like Florida should do a video
tomorrow going I feel good I love life
I'm not going to commit suicide you're
not gonna find me on a tree with an
electrical cord and two shots and no gun
it's a suicide yes yeah she's like she's
like Joe Pesci in the in Goodfellas when
she's just going away way too far we're
only like a week away from the Durham
report yeah where like like she okay her
campaign made it up she's paid for the
Steele dossier the FBI the intelligence
community that they all colluded
together and Hillary is still out there
going hey Florida I don't think you're
safe you might have a problem down there
talk about bowls yeah true you know uh
did you listen to any of the uh the
announcement on Twitter I didn't know
about it until I heard about the
glitches so the glitches helped
I didn't listen to it no
Rhonda Sanders I I agree Julia it's
weird like he's 10 years older than I am
but I feel like he could be my dad I
don't know why he just I think yeah he
is kind of boring which I guess some
people say is a good thing but just
because he's boring we'll stop all these
people from saying things about him it
is a little embarrassing that the
glitches happened I think whenever you
hype something up and then it doesn't
work yeah that's really sad but I I also
am surprised that Trump didn't like
claim responsibility for it
all day to be like how do you like that
Twitter like didn't have to be true but
just to be like what if maybe I think
that going forward the the 25 minute
glitch is going to be
repeatedly brought up by Trump over and
over and over again and I don't know
it's gonna be it's going to be tough
it's going to be tough it's an
interesting comparison though when you
think about it because
Trump's announcement was the the
escalator right and it came down and
then he said something that like just
exploded like he talked about they're
not sending their best people or
something like that and this is just
this is so DeSantis it's a glitch
because I wasted too much time on that
person
so the left thinks they've got the
formula to beat Trump
down patent so they can't afford a
DeSantis or a Scott or or Haley or the
literally most diverse right competent
group running for president no one's
selling celebrating that yeah that's
true the network of diversity is like
look at the Republican party yeah you
have a representative literally from
every corner of the of the planet
culturally nothing because they know
they think they can beat Trump so
they're going to have to destroy the
Sanders they're going to destroy
everyone who comes out because they
think if they can get him to the general
they can beat him so that's where
president Trump has to be tricky and
maybe he starts praising the people he's
running against because CNN's going to
do all your heavy lifting for you like
the stories that they're doing because
they think we want Trump because we beat
them before they think they can beat him
again all right we've got to move on hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else